Guten Morgen Dinos.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Tut mir leid, aber ich äh müsste jetzt erst nochmal ein Passwort für dein Telefon bekommen, bevor wir hier anfangen können.
Nein.
Lokbodennetzpolitik Nummer zweihundertelf mit leichten Anlaufschwierigkeiten, weil ich hier nicht den richtigen Zugang äh ins Gespräch finden kann. Wie soll ich mich denn hier mit dir unterhalten, wenn ich äh keinen Hintergrundcheck äh durchführen kann bei dir.
Ist es freiwillig oder.
Das wird sich dann schon noch herausstellen für dich.
Ja, Smartphone, großes Thema.
Ja, auf jeden Fall nicht nur beim Daddeln.
Wir haben ja äh in der letzten Woche über Smartphones gesprochen, nämlich über die Nutzung von Smartphones im,
Untersuchungsausschuss im ersten parlamentarischen Untersuchungsausschuss und da haben wir einen interessanten Kommentar zu gehabt von die Erziehungsberechtigten.
Sagte die Person schreibt.
Die wird, die genießen ja eigentlich generell eine gewisse Autorität, ne? Ja, ja. Könnten wir mal wieder.
Ja, ja, den, also immer wieder auch Kritik ausgesetzt, ne, mit großer Macht kommt großer Verantwortung.
Es ging mir auch so, deswegen habe ich vor einigen Wochen eine Petition diesbezüglich eingereicht. Die Petition lautet, der Bundestag möge beschließen, dass die gewählten Vertreter des Volkes gemeint sind, die Mitglieder des Bundestags,
künftig ihrem Auftrag der Wähler nachkommend konstruktiv über Parteigrenzen hinweg Politik,
zu betreiben und daher ihre Smartphone-Nutzung während der Redezeit der Politiker anderer Parteien
einstellen. Begründung im Schulunterricht deutscher Schulen wäre es eine Provokation, wenn während des Unterrichts ein Schüler sein Smartphone zückt und demonstrativ offen sichtbar im Netz rumsurft, möglicherweise gar Moorhühner schießt oder Towerdefense zockt
Von daher ist es ein Unding und alles andere als eine Erfüllung der Vorbildfunktion. Wenn die
wenn dies die gewählten Vertreter im Bundestag tun, insbesondere dann, wenn es in der Redezeit gewählter Politiker anderer Parteien geht.
Ist leider äh abgelehnt worden mit der Begrüfung Begründung nach Prüfung aller Gesichtspunkte. Kommt er zu dem Ergebnis, dass der Deutsche Bundestag ihrer Petation nicht zustimmen wird,
Ja, die Frage der Nutzung von mobilen Telekommunikationsgeräten im Plenarsaal hat bereits in der Vergangenheit entsprechende Gremien beschäftigt
et cetera PP und so weiter und sie meinen ja, dass der Tablet Computer ein super Schreibblockersatz sind und das könnte man ihnen ja nicht wegnehmen.
Ja, sehr schön. Zuletzt hat das Präsidium am siebenundzwanzigsten Oktober einvernehmlich schon bestehende Regelungen bestätigt, wonach das Telefonieren und der Gebrauch von Laptops im Plenarsaal nicht gestattet sind. Zugleich wurde vereinbart das Tab Gebrauch von Tablet-Computern und ähnlichen Geräten, die nicht aufgeklappt werden müssen
zulässig ist. Sehr schön, oder? Also Laptop nicht, ne.
Tablet hingegen ja.
Da sieht man mal wieder auch den äh leichte Unterschiede, kulturelle Unterschiede zwischen Europa und Amerika während er sich hier bevorzugt geräuschlos gearbeitet wird, ist das ja in USA gerade überhaupt nicht der Fall. Gut.
Er ist also ein schöner, ein schöner, ein schönes Bombo. Dann ähm eigentlich das große Thema, über das wir in dieser Sendung reden wollten und müssten.
Aber nicht tun werden.
Aber nicht tun werden, das schweigen wir tot, Lügen, dass Lügen pressen wir weg ähm Merkel, Angela Merkel war ja zu Gast im.
NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss.
Camio Auftritt.
Und ähm Andre war natürlich dort und äh da die technische Aufklärung war dort
Und Andre schreibt aber jetzt noch so an seinem Mammut Artikel zum Thema und wollte unbedingt erst seinen Artikel zum NS-Aua veröffentlichen bevor er mit uns dann am kommenden Montag ein so ein NS-Auer Spezial machen wird.
Wahrscheinlich nur NS Auer und nur Merkel.
Genau, weil das steht ja eh nah an und äh von daher verschieben wir das Thema auf die nächste Woche und äh kümmern uns um die anderen Sachen. Zum Beispiel und um um unseren Innenminister.
Genau, heute widmen wir uns dem Innenminister, denn der Innenminister hat uns etwas äh aufgeklärt über zweifelhafte Grundannahmen,
Die äh die Debatte über Privatsphäre vernebeln und ähm Datenschutz dürfte nicht,
super Grundrecht sein, das hat er äh bei einer Veranstaltung im Telefonica-Basecamp,
gesagt, die die Data die Base,
Das ist äh also das Basecamp ist in Berlin so eine Niederlassung war ursprünglich glaube ich von E Plus. Ähm das ist so,
von dem von den Lobbyisten die Veranstaltungslocation so ein bisschen, ne? Machen sie irgendwie.
So die Sitzkissen Lounge, wo man da so.
Ja, da kann man dann irgendwie mal äh kann man sich mal treffen, kann man mal einen Empfang machen, kann man mal irgendwie so eine Podiumsdiskussion machen und Tagesspiegel und Telefonika haben sich da eben den,
Herrn Demazir hinbestellt und der sagt dann, also die die
absolute unsinnige Losung, meine Daten gehören mir, die hätten ja, hätte ja schon neunzehnhundertdreiundachtzig wäre die ja schon oft zu hören gewesen im Streit um die Volkszählung und mit der würde heute noch Stimmung gemacht.
Und all die Juristen sei klar, dass das damit angedeutete Eigentum an Personen bezogene Informationen gar nicht,
dass es das gar nicht gibt und das außerdem nicht im Sinne eines absoluten rechts geschützt sei. Das ist relativ äh,
relativ.
Mutig, eine relativ mutige Aussage, die ich ähm schon öfter so höre. Ich habe vor einiger Zeit eine Veranstaltung besucht auf der,
der Verfassungsschutzchef Maaßen sprach, der sich dann auch äh dazu,
darüber ausgelassen hat und deren allgemeine Strategie,
Im Umgang mit der mit der den Datenschützern in Deutschland geht daraufhin
die so ein bisschen als gestrig darzustellen. Also
Ne, so, ey, schon in den Achtzigerjahren, äh, haben die da unter denen hat sich nichts geändert, ne? Die haben ja überhaupt nichts verstanden, die sind ja stehengeblieben in den Achtzigerjahren. Währenddessen gibt's Multimedia und und Datenautobahn,
und diese äh das ist also quasi jetzt deren deren Strategie gegen Datenschutz, ähm die man bei diesen Debatten immer wieder sieht,
äh kombiniert dann mit ja und das macht,
dem Mazia hier auch. Dann geht's auf Facebook, ne? Also Facebook hier alle der Datenexibitionismus in sozialen Netzwerken auch das exakt Maßen, ja? Äh letztes Jahr schon. Und wahrscheinlich auch schon Jahre davor, ja. Ähm.
Äh das beklagen sie sich also ähm darüber, dass,
Der Exibisusexibitionismus in sozialen äh Netzwerken einerseits stattfinde ähm
Maaßen hatte da letztes Jahr dann auch irgendwie gesagt, so ja, das ist ein Problem für die nationale Sicherheit ist, ne, weil ja dann die Leute ausspioniert werden auf Facebook und äh erpressbar werden oder was auch immer,
Ja, da geht's also
da geht's jetzt rund und die werden diese Arten von Angriffen jetzt bei jeder Gelegenheit fahren, ne? Also es wird irgendwie auch, ne, gerade wenn man jetzt sieht, NS Auer ist vorbei
dann wird's Zeit auch ein bisschen wieder in die Offensive zu kommen, ne? Und äh mutig zu sein und sich eben gegen diese ewig gestrigen,
Datenschützer äh zu setzen.
Ja, also das äh,
da scheinen mal wieder mal ein paar Leute mal ein paar Talking Points zusammen geschrieben zu haben, da kommt man doch ganz schön ins äh ins schwere Atmen,
richtig geil finde ich ja in dem Zusammenhang wieder diese Formulierung des super Grundrechts. Steht komischerweise immer noch nicht in der Wikipedia als eigenes Lemma,
gibt's wahrscheinlich gar nicht, ja? Wir erinnern uns, das gab's glaube ich äh ursprünglich mal von unserem äh ehemaligen Innenminister Herrn Friedrich von der CSU.
Der ja von einem super Grundrecht auf Sicherheit sprach seinerzeit.
Genau. Mhm.
Kommt das, glaube ich, äh her. Und jetzt wird es umgedreht und wird gesagt, na ja, Datenschutz sei ja gar kein super Grundrecht
glaube ich auch so. Bisher noch überhaupt niemand äh behauptet hat, weil ich glaube niemand äh in dieser Diskussionsfähre auch nur die Existenz eines super Grundrechts als solches ähm bestätigen können äh könnte oder wollte,
Grundrecht reicht ja eigentlich auch und meine Sichtweise ist insofern ganz interessant, als das natürlich gerade in dieser Zeit in den achtziger Jahren mit der ersten Volkszählung,
Das Thema ja überhaupt erstmalig auch in der höchsten äh Rechtsprechung aufkam und des Verfassungsgerichts sich ja dann in einigen Wegweisenden
Entscheidungen, im Prinzip überhaupt erstmal sich zu diesem Thema äh bekannt hat, wo dann ja unter anderem eben auch so dieses,
man verfügt erstmal selber über das äh von einem selbstgespeicherte da kommt das ja im Prinzip alles her,
Also das sozusagen dann schon als äh rückständig zu bezeichnen, wo man doch da eigentlich gerade erst die Geburt dieses gesamten Gedankens gefeiert hat. Das finde ich ganz lustig.
Interessant ist, worauf zieht er denn ab, ne? Muss man hier noch ein bisschen äh weiter zitieren,
Ja, ich zitiere jetzt einfach mal ganz kurz hier aus dem Heiser Artikel. Je attraktiver Daten nun als Wirtschaftsgut würden, desto höher sei das Interesse auch im Firmensektor an Eigentum daran,
führte dem Maisier aus. Manche Rechtswissenschaftler wollten gar die Ausschließlichkeitsrechte des Sach
Sachrechts auf Daten anwenden, dabei gerade aus dem Blick, dass es sich im Kern um Informationen, Ideen, Wissen und Meinungen handele, deren freier Fluss Teil der Marktwirtschaftlichen und demokratischen Ordnung sei
Nur an bearbeiteten Daten könnten entsprechende Schutz und Eigentumsrechte bestehen und dann warnt er, wenn jeder seine Daten veräußern könne, besteht die Gefahr des Ausverkaufs der Privatsphäre,
dann seien nur noch wohlhabende fähig, sich Zurückhaltung zu leisten.
Ich frage mich ernsthaft wohl, was das für ein für ein cooles Argument ist.
Na äh also bei Winnie bin ich das ist ein bisschen schwierig zu verstehen. Meint er vielleicht zielt das hier primär auf Unternehmen.
Geht es hier um die Datenbestände der Unternehmen und den Zugriff da drauf. Ich meine man,
mir ist gerade gar nicht so sicher, ob man jetzt hier äh unmittelbar einen Angriff auf Daten des Individuums äh rauslesen kann oder ob er nicht sehr viel mehr von ähm,
ja, einer doch durchaus unterstützenswerten Formulierung, ja, dass diese Daten ja Ideen, Wissen und Meinungen repräsentieren,
äh falsch, ja? Und dass es dort sozusagen einen gewissen freien Fluss geben muss im Sinne von, da können dann Firmen nicht drauf,
Sitzen und sagen, das darf nicht weitergegeben werden. Also interessante Vorlage auch vielleicht für eine Copyright-Debatte, aber ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht so ganz genau, worauf er hinaus will. Also was er hier eigentlich wirklich,
anstrebt in seiner Formulierung.
Ich glaube ihm geht es.
Darum Datenschutz zu schwächen, ne? Also das ist einfach mal das, das,
ganz klar, ne? Also er sagt ja dann auch, irre Gesichtweise, Datenschutz würde Datenschutz, eine ist totaler Unsinn. Aber das mit diesem
Ich weiß nicht, wo wohin er mit dem Argument möchte, also es ist heute schon ein Fakt, dass es für das wohlhabende möglich ist, weniger
mehr Datenschutz zu haben, ne? Datenschutzfreundlichere Dienste zu nutzen ähm,
Dinge Dinge zu bezahlen, um nicht mit den eigenen Daten bezahlen zu müssen. Und ich glaube, dass er so ein bisschen.
Also seine Argumentation geht so ein bisschen an der Entwicklung vorbei, ja? Daten.
Persönliche Daten, personenbezogene Daten, das, das lässt er hier ja ziemlich außen vor, dass es sich um personenbezogene Daten handelt und nicht um irgendwie Ideen, Wissen und so weiter, sondern es geht um
Datensätze, die über Personen angefertigt werden und die dann monetarisiert werden. Das ist ja leider immer noch das Einzige,
Was uns eingefallen ist als Menschheit, wie man mit diesem Internet halbwegs Geld machen kann
ne? Gut, abgesehen von irgendwie andere Dienstleistungen wie Filme darüber äh darüber zu verballern oder oder Musikstreaming, aber.
Die eine Möglichkeit Content zu finanzieren im Internet ist durch Daten sammeln also eigentlich Überwachung und Vermarktung und dann und dann Werbung.
Und er sagt jetzt irgendwie so, ja das das muss muss auch mal sein. Da muss man unbedingt den Datenschutz nicht so nicht so wild sehen, dass äh die Firmen eben diese Daten sammeln dürfen,
dass der, dass man möglichst wenig Eigentumsrecht daran ja äh den Menschen gebe,
und diese Losung, dass es dass die Daten den Menschen gehören würden, hält er eben für falsch und das halte ich für für nicht falsch,
Es ist eine ziemlich, es ist natürlich eine irrige Annahme, dass man jetzt, dass man davon äh dass man davon ausgeht, man sei jetzt irgendwie ein Mensch und man habe irgendwie Daten
und gebe diese den Unternehmen, nein dem Unternehmen fertigen die ja an und genau da will er ja den Schutz haben, da sagt er nur an bearbeiteten Daten können Schutz und Eigentumsrechte entstehen ne? Mh und da will er natürlich die Rolle der Unternehmen,
stärken und ihnen das Sammeln von Daten vereinfachen und den Menschen, die sich dagegen wehren möchten, äh deren Position zu schwächen.
Bist du dir da so sicher? Also ich tendiere fast dazu eher das.
Na ja, also hier steht ja, steht ja spezifisch als ähm wenn, wenn es zutreffe, dass Datenschutzdaten schützt, dann äh würde Datenschutzherz zu einem super Grundrecht aufwachsen. Ähm.
Er unterstricht, dass,
Dass der Schutz gut die Persönlichkeit und das Selbstbestimmungsrecht seien, dies weise in Richtung Datensouveränität die Teile der Bundesregierung sowie Verbände der Digitalwirtschaft seit einiger Zeit bevorzugen,
Nun ja, ist ja auch am Ende eine eine vielleicht eine philosophische Debatte, aber ähm ich denke, dass es.
Wo kommt denn dieser Begriff Datensouveränität her, den habe ich jetzt in dem Zusammenhang noch gar nicht gehört.
Wo der genau herkommt, weiß ich nicht, aber den äh kenne ich durchaus schon, ist schon länger.
Aber was repräsentiert der? Also wer wer ist hier Datensuper.
Der Seil im Prinzip sagt er, dass du äh Datenschutz in Anspruch nehmen kannst.
Dass du, dass du die Hoheit über deine Daten weiterhin behältst. Ich sehe unsere Debatte gleitet gerade in einer Haarspalterei ab, die kaum der nicht mehr zu folgen ist, muss ich sagen.
Ja, ja, ich äh.
IT-Gipfel zwanzig sech.
Möchte nur zur Kenntnis geben, dass mir das nicht so eindeutig klar ist, was ja eigentlich gesagt wird. Und ich äh ehrlich gesagt noch nicht mal dazu tendiere, es sind die eine oder andere Richtung auslegen zu woll.
Deren Ziel ist, die Datenerfassung zu vereinfachen. Ähm IT-Gipfel zwanzig sechzehn hat Merkel diesen Begriff der Datensouveränität geprägt und ähm.
Prinzipiell sehen sie Datenschutz. Also die Datenschutzrechte in Deutschland als lähmenden Faktor für die Wirtschaft an und möchten das möchten gerne,
und Datensparsamkeit sehen sie auch als Problem an, kann nicht die Richtschnur sein für neue Produkte,
Und sie möchten also lieber äh die Datensparsamkeit auflösen, sich vom Prinzip der Datensparsamkeit trennen, die Erfassung von Daten äh vereinfachen,
Und.
Dann eine Souveränität zu fordern, dass die, dass die, dass du quasi ähm besseren Überblick darüber hast, aber dass die Erhebung von Daten vereinfacht wird.
Und hier steht jetzt in dem Artikel, dass das der der Begriff ursprünglich von Sigmar Gabriel kommt
So oder so, wenn ein Innenminister über Datenschutz redet, ja, ähm dann weißt du ungefähr, wo's wo die Reise hingeht und äh ich habe das eigentlich auch nur kurz aufgedisen, diese Meldung mit aufgenommen. Als Einleitung für das Hauptthema
unserer Sendung,
nämlich äh Datenschutz, ne, ist ja dieses Konzept aus den Achtzigern, das ist ja vorbei.
Und jetzt ist ja äh zweitausend noch, weil zweitausendsiebzehn sogar und äh jetzt ist ja Flüchtlingsproblematik und die muss ja irgendwie gelöst werden. Jetzt ähm.
Ist es so, ein eines der Problemfelder, wenn,
Menschen nach Deutschland fliehen und Asyl beantragen ist, dass sie nicht selten keinen Pass bei sich haben.
Kann verschiedene Gründe haben, warum sie keinen haben, ein möglicher Grund ist, dass sie aus einem Land kommen, dass nicht asylberechtigt ist. Ne, also einem aus einem sicheren Drittstaat und wenn du aus einem, wenn du jetzt aus,
keine Ahnung. Aus Marokko oder sowas kommst oder Tunesien oder was weiß ich.
Da ist alles okay.
Da ist alles in Ordnung, da kriegst du prinzipiell kein,
Asyl in Deutschland. Das sind aber sehr sehr langwierige Verfahren und wenn da so ein Mensch sitzt, die wissen natürlich aus welchem Land äh man kommen muss, damit man Asyl bekommt,
und sagen naturgemäß natürlich dann, dass sie aus einem dieser Länder sind. Und jetzt stehen dann die steht die die deutschen Behörden, stehen vor der Herausforderung.
Herauszufinden, woher die Menschen kommen, um zu sehen, ob die überhaupt berechtigt sind, einen Asylantrag zu erstellen. Und gleichzeitig natürlich auch, um zu wissen, wenn das nicht der Fall ist, wohin man die Leute abschiebt,
Ja, die oder freiwillig wieder ausreißt,
ja und ähm das Verfahren, was man wohl heute macht, ist ähm kommt da ein Dolmetscher,
der sich mit regionalen Dialekten auskennt,
und der dann quasi anhand der dessen, was die Person, wie die Person spricht und was sie so erzählt im Prinzip eine Plausibilitätsprüfung macht, ob die aus dem Land sind,
dass dass sie behaupten, ja? Ähm!
Also zum Beispiel sagen, ich komme, ich komme aus Syrien, ja, ich komme aus Syrien, dass man dann irgendwie sagt, ja, komisch, du sprichst aber.
Der der Syrien sehr untypisch ist, wann bist du denn nach Syrien gegangen? Wo hast du denn da gewohnt äh und irgendwie solche solche Dinge? Und jetzt kam die Idee,
zu sagen, na ja, vielleicht wenn diese Menschen über andere Möglichkeiten der Beweisführung verfügen.
Dass sie aus einem bestimmten Land kommen, dann sollte man doch die Möglichkeit ergreifen, formuliere es jetzt mal positiv,
Dass sie diese Beweisführung anbringen, zum Beispiel, indem sie einen Zugang auf ein Facebook-Profil ermöglichen.
Und in dem Facebook-Profil, dass es dann von mir aus, ne? Fünf Jahre alt und äh da wurden wurden jeden Monat drei Bilder gepostet und die Bilder haben Meterdaten,
Und da sieht man, ne, wurden mit dem Handy gepostet, da ist ein GPS mit drin. Ähm dann sieht man die Leute irgendwie.
Wie sie in Syrien oder in welchem Land auch immer vor ihrer Freizeit Bilder machen und dann können sie damit quasi den Nachweis führen, dass sie aus einem bestimmten Land kommen oder eben nicht.
Und.
Der einzige Nachteil dieser ganzen Angelegenheit ist eben, dass mit diesem, mit diesem Datenschutz, ne? Dass du die Leute nämlich, äh, dass du im Prinzip einen forensischen Zugriff auf das Telefon haben möchtest, ne?
Die USA haben da ja jetzt auch irgendwie schon diese diese Regelung, wir wollen mal deine Social Media Passwörter haben, um da reinzublicken. Ähm,
und in in Deutschland möchte man's halt erstmal nur mit Geflüchteten machen. Äh denen soll es übrigens so verkauft werden, dass es natürlich nicht verpflichtend ist,
sondern optional optin,
Sie können auch gerne mehrere Jahre warten auf einen Termin mit unserem Dolmetscher, solange äh hier hängt ihr Verfahren dann in der Schwebe oder sie, sie führen diesen diese Beweis an, den sie in ihrer.
Gerade zu einer Abkürzung. Mhm. Abkürzungen in die Freiheit.
Das BMI schätzt, dass im Jahr zwanzigsechzehn bei fünfzig bis sechzig Prozent der Asylsuchenden
dieses ein solches Auslesen in Betracht gekommen wäre. Also wir reden hier so, dass wir dann die Größenordnung von hundertfünfzigtausend Menschen,
Und sie planen jetzt die Außenstellen des Bundesamtes für Migration und Flüchtlinge mit so Forensik, Hard und Software auszurüsten, sodass etwa zweitausendvierhundert Datenträger pro Tag ausgelesen werden,
können.
Was heißt denn das? Das ist in Betracht gekommen wäre.
Nö, die die haben diese Software nicht, die haben das nicht, die haben weder die rechtliche Grundlage noch die Ausstattung. Die sind ähm tatsächlich gerade dabei, sich zu überlegen, wie man das denn machen kann,
man da kauft, ne? Sie würden das naheliegend bewähren, irgendwelche sind die klassischen Forensi,
und Software zu kaufen, die so ein, diese einfach so ein Telefon dampfen und dann marschierst du halt einmal durch. Eine Möglichkeit wäre jetzt, ne? Also ich spinne mal rum. Du du saugst alle Bilder von dem Telefon runter.
Und äh liest die Meterdaten aus den Bildern aus und visualisierst das auf so einer Karte, ne? Und dann kannst du sagen, auf dem Telefon sind waren zweihundert Fotos ähm.
Belegen deine Reiseroute.
Hundertfünfundachtzig davon konnte, konnten wir Meterdaten äh entnehmen äh,
Und hier ist die Reiseroute, die diese Person oder wir färben die Länder ein, in denen sich die Person aufgehalten hat, ähm kann man natürlich dann auch so äh wie wie würde man sagen.
Personen, also sparsam machen, ne, da einen Sparsam, dass man jetzt vielleicht einfach nur die ausgelesenen Meterdaten auf einer Karte visualisiert, ne
sagte, indem aus diesem Land kommt diese Person ähm,
Und ja, dass man dann irgendwie die Selfies ausliest und sagt, ja, hier ist ein Selfie, damit das hat natürlich höheren Wert, weil äh da ist die Person ja dann auch drauf und äh hat nicht einfach äh quasi das Telefon gefälscht.
Das Interessante ist, wenn du diesen Ansatz technisch verfolgst, dann wäre natürlich dieser Einblick in das Facebook-Profil wäre das.
Im Prinzip klügste, was du machen könntest, weil das.
Aus welcher äh Position heraus das Glückste.
Also als Überlegung für die Analyse, weil Facebook wirst du, du wirst kein Facebook-Profil fälschen können im Nachhinein, ne? Du kannst vor allem auch zum Beispiel beim Facebook-Profil nicht den Namen ändern.
Das heißt, es müsste,
du kannst jetzt nicht irgendwie oder vielleicht geht das schon, aber ich glaube nicht so wirklich, dass du jetzt irgendwie sagst, ich lade jetzt mal was auf Facebook hoch und lasse das so aussehen, als hätte ich das vor vor sechs Jahren schon hochgeladen,
Das heißt diese ein, die Stimmigkeit eines Facebook-Profiles äh,
mit der die Nachweist, dass das dass du eine Person bist, die die ganze Zeit in Syrien gelebt hat, obwohl du es nicht getan hast, dieses Facebook-Profil zu fälschen, ist sicherlich schwieriger
Als Mobiltelefon zu nehmen und da irgendwie gefälschte Meterdaten reinzufahren. Also in.
Draufzuladen. Genau. Wobei man das natürlich dann auch noch wieder legen könnte, aber.
Kann man alles machen, aber ich glaube so.
Rein von einer Herangehensweise wäre die Möglichkeit auf ein Facebook-Profil zuzugreifen schon eine relativ kluge. Ja? Wegen Fälschungssicherheit.
Nochmal kurz eine Nachfrage, weil diese Formulierung hat mich so ein bisschen äh stutzen lassen.
Ja es ist hier das BMI schätzt dass das Auslesen eines Datenträgers.
Bei fünfzig Prozent bis sechzig Prozent der Asylsochene Asylsuchenden in Betracht gekommen wäre. Was heißt denn das in Betracht, dass ähm,
Dort eine Zustimmung vorlag oder dass es eine eine Lageeinschätzung gab, dass man das jetzt hier eigentlich ganz gerne getan hätte, wenn man's denn nur könnte oder wenn man's nur dürfte.
Heißt, es wäre eine es es scheint eine sinnvoll. Es hätte eine sinnvolle Option sein können.
Unabhängig von der Zustimmung.
Ja, es im ja, natürlich. Die haben ja jetzt nicht, die haben ja jetzt nicht erfasst, würden sie zustimmen? In Betracht in Betracht heißt, es wäre überhaupt eine Möglichkeit.
Ja, das heißt, dass sie das bisher noch nie getan haben.
Ja, sie, das habe ich aber gerade schon gesagt, dass sie die Tools dafür nicht haben. Die sind gerade dabei.
Nein, ich meine, wenn jetzt Asylsuchende zustimmen und sagen, ja, hier Telefon. Guck doch mal.
Ja von sich aus werden die da nicht drauf. Also es kann auch sein, dass aber das doch glaube ich unerheblich für.
Wenn du da äh wenn du da äh aufläufst und die sagen immer, ja, sage ich mal, beweis mal, beweis mir mal mit deinem Gerät, dass dass das stimmt, was du da sagst.
Gerade wenn es stimmt. Ich meine dann ist auch sicherlich eine relativ hohe Bereitschaft da das auch zu tun.
In dem in den Prüfungen. Es geht ihnen da gerade nicht darum, dass jemand in einem Gespräch mal sein Handy rausholt und sagt, guck mal hier,
Ich habe, ne? Also in dem Gespräch mit diesem Dolmetscher sagt, ja ja genau, ich komme aus, haste nicht gesehen, Aleppo. Und guck mal, hier habe ich ein Bild gemacht, das ist mein Haus, ist jetzt kaputt und sowas, ne? Darum geht es nicht. Es geht hier,
um das massenhafte Auslesen von zweitausendvierhundert Telefonen am Tag.
Mit äh Spezial Hard und Software. Unter Ausnutzung von äh mitunter vielleicht Schwachstellen an diesen Geräten.
Und das äh Nutzen von dieser Hard- und Software, die da existiert, die existiert natürlich zu ganz anderen Zwecken, ne? Das sind halt äh ja, Forensik-Tools, ne? Also
aus der Strafverfolgung,
stammt sowas, ne? Wo ein Handy äh im Drogendealer ein Handy weggenommen, dann wird das an so ein Ding gesteckt und und damit einmal alle Daten raus und und bringt die, gibt die zur Analyse. Und die interessieren sich für ähm interessieren sich für,
Eine sinnvolle Möglichkeit, wo du diese Kapazität hinkriegst. Zweitausendvierhundert Telefone
Am Tag an so ein Ding zu stecken, ne? Dass das die Daten da runterholen. Ich weiß nicht, wie lange sowas dauert. Ein paar Minuten, je nachdem, was auf dem Telefon drauf ist, kann's ja auch eventuell die Analyse auf dem Telefon machen. Die sind,
Dabei, also sie haben noch nicht die fertige technische Lösung.
Sind aber gerade dabei, sich umzuhören äh oder uns sich Gedanken zu machen, die wollen aber auf jeden Fall nicht so etwas wie,
Du zeigst mal ein Foto, sondern die wollen, steckt dein Telefon da dran. Wir wir dampfen den, wir holen uns den gesamten Datenreichtum und äh versuchen möglichst automatisiert,
'ne schnelle Aussage zu treffen. So was wie Syrien oder Tunesien,
Schweiz oder USA? Ja ist richtig, der kommt aus den USA, der ist asylbertrechtig. Ähm das ist natürlich schon eine ganz andere Ebene,
und das das.
Sehr perfide daran ist natürlich, sie fangen damit an bei den Schwächsten, ne? Also bei Menschen, die Asyl suchen.
Und sagen dann, die ist freiwillig, ne? Du kannst auch, ist gar kein Problem. Du kannst gerne dich dem äh mehrere Jahre andauernden langwierigen Prozess zuführen, äh wenn du das verweigerst hier.
Kriegst du natürlich dann auch eine eine Notiz in der Akte, dass du uns nicht diesen Zugriff gegeben hast.
Also die Freiwilligkeit ist da nicht gegeben, ne? Ist genauso wie äh die Freiwilligkeit durch diesen Nacktscanner am Flughafen zu gehen. Wenn du das, wenn du dich weigerst, ja okay, dann kommst du halt in die lang und langsame Schlange,
bequem sich halt irgendwann mal jemand zu dir und tastet dich ab, ne?
Aber es wird dir auf jeden Fall nicht einfach gemacht. Das heißt, dieses Berufen auf Freiwilligkeit oder so ist natürlich hier eine.
Eine eine Fake News. Da wird ein wird ein wird ein ein Damm gebrochen und äh und gut ist,
Und dann kannst du davon ausgehen, wir haben,
haben das glaube ich ja nur nur am Rande erwähnt. In den USA ist das ja heute schon äh jetzt tatsächlich so eine für Trump eine völlig normale äh legitime Regulierung, die aber glaube ich sogar schon aus äh außerorma Zeiten kommt.
Dass die äh Zugriff auf deine äh auf deinen Social Network Telefit verlangen können.
Und man kann das auch äh ich habe da einige interessante Gespräche drüber geführt mit Leuten. Ähm du kannst das natürlich irgendwie Daten sparsam oder datenschonend.
Bauen, ne, sowas wie okay, wir speichern die Daten nicht und wir löschen die den API-Zug Zugang auch aus Facebook wieder nach einem Tag und ähm aber es beinhaltet nun mal, ja, die äh,
Der Staat möchte einmal,
in dein in dein, deine, in dein komplettes Telefon schauen und in deinem Telefon sind SMS, sind Kontakte, sind Fotos, alles ist alles mögliche, alles Datenquellen, die man heranziehen könnte, um eine valide,
Prognose deines Herkunfts oder ja eine valide Schätzung deines Herkunftslandes zu machen. Und dann könnte die Software auch sagen, okay, sind nicht genug Daten drauf oder hier sind Bilder drauf, die habe ich schon mal gesehen. Das ist ein Enttäuschungsversuch, der hier stattfindet
oder sonst was, aber was eben leider nicht geschehen darf, ist, dass wir hm so lieb das hier auch gemeint sein kann, äh dass wir zulassen.
Dass dass das äh dass das eine eine legitime Forderung wird. Gib mal dein Telefon.
Oder hast du das zu verbergen? Ja, gib Handy.
Ich hörte so.
Ja gut, das Ganze ist jetzt ein Gesetzentwurf, der von der äh süddeutschen äh geliegt wurde und ähm.
Geliegt ist. Also er wurde über.
Darüber informiert sind,
der ihnen vorliegt. Der aber offenbar noch in dieser Legislaturperiode ähm angeschoben werden soll, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Also, sonst wird es ja wohl relativ wenig Sinn machen, äh darüber zu diskutieren.
Ich wollte das mal ein bisschen ähm ich habe das jetzt vor, ich habe jetzt das Positivbeispiel gebracht, ne? Nämlich, dass die Leute äh, dass den Leuten eine Möglichkeit gegeben wird, ähm.
Ihre legitime Herkunft schnell unter Beweis zu stellen, ne? Also für.
Man könnte sich ja durchaus vorstellen, dass die die Menschen die Ehe alles hinter sich gelassen haben und äh auf auf einer auf ein neues Leben hoffen.
Da jetzt auch nicht mehr den großen Einwand haben, ne? Also ich kann mir schwer vorstellen oder ich glaube, dass die der geringere Teil der Leute da protestieren wird,
Wenn die irgendwie geflohen sind,
aus ganz fürchterlichen Bedingungen und dann gesagt wird, ey, gib Handy, so, dass sie das dann halt machen und sagen, okay, alles klar, kann ich jetzt rein, wunderbar. Schnellere, schnelleres Asylverfahren hier ähm Premium,
Premium Boarding, ne? Handycheck in. Und ähm.
Ist mir ein Handy-Checkout.
Das habe ich im Moment, ich hab's sehr positiv ja jetzt formuliert. Das Gesetz heißt, hat aber natürlich einen ganz anderen Ansatz, ne? Das Gesetz äh lautet,
Gesetz zur besseren Durchsetzung der Ausreisepflicht. Ja, damit wollen sie natürlich schnell die Leute, die Leute erfassen, die behaupten, aus irgendeinem Land zu kommen und die dann, das ist ja der das Problem, was sie dann haben,
Die müssen ja alle vernünftig geprüft werden
diese Asylanträge und dann muss eben eine Herkunftsfeststellung unternommen werden. Und das äh erfordert eben Sprachgutachten, gezielte Nachfragen über äh landestypisches Wissen und so weiter
touristische Attraktionen und so, weil wir machen einfach im Prinzip Plausibilitätsprüfung in Gesprächen, das ist zeitaufwendig und teuer.
Und ähm das wollen sie jetzt eben effizienter gestalten. Und äh es geht eben darum, dann Menschen, die,
Die Einreise zu verwehren.
Oder die Ausreise zu ermöglichen, wenn die schon äh hier sind in dem äh Artikel, den wir hier zitieren aus der SZ. Äh gibt's übrigens noch einen anderen interessanten Fall, den ich jetzt noch gar nicht so gesehen hatte. Vorher, das äh
Hilfebericht von einem Serben aus Oberhausen, der im Internet nach Lastwagen recherchiert habe und äh das,
Resultierte wohl in einem entsprechenden Facebook-Post, den dann die Ermittler zum Anlass genommen haben, es könnte ja die Ankündigung eines Anschlags sein, woraufhin sie dann ihn festgenommen und aus sofort ausgewiesen,
hätten.
Ja, geil. Ähm vielleicht auch nochmal kurz zu dem Hintergrund.
Also nicht nur mit nach Lastwagen suchen. Leute. Also es müssen nicht auf Facebook.
Hintergrund ist äh auch Anis Amri äh der wie wir ja wissen, vierzehn verschiedene Identitäten hat,
jedes Mal, wenn er mit den Behörden in Kontakt gekommen ist, gesagt hat, ja aber ich bin der und der, mit der und der. Im Prinzip jedes Mal andere Papiere gehabt oder keine Papiere gehabt
Er hat dann irgendwie erklärt, er sei falsch verstanden worden. Der Dolmetscher habe irgendwas falsch übersetzt, er kann sich nicht erinnern
Dieses Spiel geht natürlich, wenn du jetzt mit Facebook kommst, nur sehr schwer,
Du müsstest ja jedes dieser Identitäten über Jahre gefälscht haben. Insofern ist das.
Skurril, aber wir sind an dem Punkt, dass du wahrscheinlich am besten deine Identität heute über deinen Facebook über ein gut gepflegtes Facebook-Profil nachweisen kannst. Sehr viel besser, als zum Beispiel über einen Reisepass,
Wahrscheinlich ist es sogar billiger ein Reisepass zu fälschen als ein Facebookprofil.
Aber wie findest du denn das Tim? Handy rausrücken.
Problematisch. Der Mann ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass die Leute nicht äh die zukommen, nicht inselben Maße äh Rechte hätten, wie die Leute, die schon hier sind,
Ähm dem ganzen Forensisch ähm nachzugehen, halte ich für sehr problematisch. Aber ist natürlich ein.
Ein Dilemma hier, ne? Für die, für die Sicherheitsbehörden, auf der einen Seite werden sie jetzt äh für die Nachlässigkeiten in der Terrorverhandlung
Konsorten äh geprügelt, was sie denn nicht alles hätten theoretisch tun äh müssen und äh herausfinden können,
Ähm ja,
dazu mit dem Druck von rechts hier äh die harte Hand rauszuholen, um diesen ganzen äh Asylansturm, wie es immer so schön heißt, äh, Herr zu werden.
Also das Kabinett hat ihn jetzt beschlossen, das heißt, sie werden das jetzt auf den auf den Weg geben.
Hier äh werden mal wieder äh besser gewesen wären, mal richtige Rechtsanwälte hier in unserem ähm.
Ich nee, brauche ich nicht. Nee. Äh ich ich brauche da keinen Rechtsanwalt für. Das ist eine äh das ist eine eine ganz klare Frage von,
ist das wollen wir mit unserer Gesellschaft dahin oder nicht? Das keine äh juristische Frage. Wenn die das beschließen, dann kriegen sie das irgendwie durch,
Ja, dann sagen sie es ist freiwillig und dann kriegst du das auch nicht vor irgendeinem Verfassungsgericht weg.
Ja, muss da musst du eben beinhalten, äh dass äh dass du dass jemand, der ähm darauf verzichtet auf diese Möglichkeit, keinen direkten Nachteil hat und schon bist du juristisch auf mehr oder weniger auf der sicheren Seite,
Aber wichtig äh also Markus Reuter kommentiert bei Netzpolitical. Es kann nicht sein, dass Elementare Grundrechte plötzlich nicht mehr für alle gelten. Hier werden,
Geflüchtete rechtlich zu Menschen zweiter Klasse gemacht
noch mehr als dies bislang schon der Fall ist. Außerdem stellt ein solches Gesetz Asylbewerber unter einen Generalverdacht. Die Planungen des Innenministeriums bestätigen damit
all diejenigen, die in der öffentlichen Debatte seit Monaten auf schäbige Art und Weise versuchen, Asylbewerber mit Terroristen gleichzusetzen
und das Vorabend überschreitet eine rote Linie. Was erst bei Geflüchteten gemacht wird, könnte irgendwann auch bei allen anderen eingeführt werden.
Und ich denke, da hat er einen sehr äh klaren Punkt. Das Auslesen des Smartphones betrifft den unantastbaren
Kernbereich privater Lebensgestaltung, ne? Das was worüber Konstanz immer ausführlich redet, weil das natürlich die äh die ähm entscheidenden Argumente bei Staatsrealen und so weiter sind
Äh da wird eindeutig der Kernbereich äh verletzt. Und zwar vollumfänglich, ne? Das ist ein schwerer Grundrechtseingriff.
Allright. Aber wir haben ja äh doch das EU-Parlament, das wird uns ja vor allem beschützen.
Ja, genau, der Terror droht ja überall, wie wir wissen, ne? Kein Tag ohne Terror. Äh deswegen brauchen wir jetzt eine Antiterror-Richtlinie.
Und äh die hat das EU-Parlament beschlossen. Richtlinie wissen wir muss innerhalb von,
achtzehn Monaten dann in geltendes Recht an Ort und Stelle umgesetzt werden, das heißt sie.
Na, also wie die Vorratsseitenspeicherung auch, das war eine Richtlinie und dann muss äh muss das entsprechend haben die Mitgliedsstaaten Zeit die Richtlinien umzusetzen in
eigener nationaler Gesetzgebung, die auch über die Richtlinie hinausgehen kann. Ähm in der Richtlinie finden sich dann so, kann, darf, muss äh Vereinen äh Formulierungen. Und hier sagen sie, ja,
ähm wenn irgendwie Terrorpropaganda im Internet ist, dann sollte der,
sollte der Mitgliedsstaat die nötigen Maßnahmen ergreifen, um Aufrufe zu terroristischen Handlungen löschen zu lassen,
Und dann, wenn jedoch die Entfernung solcher Inhalte an der Quelle nicht durchführbar ist,
können auch Mechanismen eingerichtet werden, um den Zugang zu solchen Inhalten
vom Gebiet der Union aus zu sperren. Die von den Mitgliedsstaaten gemäß dieser Richtlinie getroffenen Maßnahmen zur Entfernung von Online-Inhalten, die eine öffentliche Aufforderung zur Begehung einer terroristischen Straftat darstellen oder,
Falls dies nicht durchfuhrbar ist, zur Sperrung des Zugangs zu solchen Inhalten könnten auf Maßnahmen des Staates etwa gesetzt gesetzgeberischer nicht gesetzgeberischer oder justizieller Art gestützt werden.
In diesem Zusammenhang lässt diese Richtlinie freiwillige Maßnahmen der Internetindustrie zur Verhinderung des Missbrauchs ihrer Dienste oder Unterstützung jedweder Art solcher Maßnahmen durch die Mitgliedsstaaten,
Wie die Aufdeckung und Kennzeichnung terroristischer Inhalte unberührt. Mit anderen Worten.
Auch gerichtlich nicht angeordnete Websperren,
sind ein legitimes Mittel gegen Onlineinhalte, die zum Beispiel Terrorismus verherrlichen. Also,
Du brauchst doch nicht mal einen Richter, äh ein Richterurteil. Es wird ermutigt, dass die Online-Anbieter das einfach selber machen,
Also sowas wie äh also Netzsperren Netzsperren auf dem kurzen Dienstweg
Kai brauchst du jetzt keine richterliche Anordnung oder so. Ne, das machen wir, machen wir Flugs nebenher. Ja ist schon in Ordnung, mach mal schnell. Ähm man muss vorher mal kurz probiert haben, man sollte probiert haben, man wird ermutigt. Ähm,
eine Löschung herbeizuführen, aber einfach mal kurz ohne ohne großartige juristischen Overhead mal eben,
vom Privatanbieter so 'ne Sperrung durchführen zu lassen, geht auch klar.
Irgendwie habe ich so das Gefühl, dass das in England und in äh in Ungarn relativ schnell in äh Region in äh nationale Gesetzgebung überführt wird.
Oder in Polen.
Gibt's da noch so einen schönen Beisatz? Unabhängig von der gewählten Handlungsgrundlage oder Methode sollten,
Die Mitgliedsstaaten sicherstellen, dass sie für die Nutzer und Diensteanbieter mit einem angemessenen Maß an Rechtssicherheit und Vorhersehbarkeit,
Sowie der Möglichkeit von Rechtsbehelfen nach nationalen Recht verbunden ist. Also es sollte, sollten sicherstellen, dass du eine Möglichkeit hast.
Sollte heißt nicht muss.
Ja
Und äh na ja, angemessenes Maß, Richtsicherheit, relativ zu dem nationalen Recht, das ist natürlich extrem schwammig,
Also wohlgemerkt es handelt sich hierbei um eine Richtlinie, das heißt etwas, was halt erst in lokale Gesetz überführt werden muss, nationales Gesetz überführt werden muss,
Ähm ich bin ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen überrascht, wie denn diese Richtlinie überhaupt zustande gekommen ist.
Haben wir da was übersehen? Oder war ich schon mal in der Diskussion.
Wenn ich mich nicht täusche, also die ist ein bisschen vom Radar verschwunden ähm w.
Überall drauf.
Wir haben da, glaube ich, schon mal drüber berichtet, weil wenn ich mich jetzt nicht täusche, du siehst mich hier nervös und schnell googeln. Ja, ja. Äh.
Liebsten.
Ist das passiert unter im Ausschuss so und so unter der guten Frau Hohlmeier.
Monika Hohlmeier und da haben wir im März zwanzig sechzehn, also ungefähr vor einem Jahr glaube ich drüber gesprochen, dass da äh wieder Netzsperren in Richtung,
Terror kommen. Bei der Gelegenheit hatten wir darüber gesprochen, dass die Frau Hohlmeier ja ähm einen interessanten Stammbaum hat.
Schön gesagt. Ja. Herkunft.
Denn sie ist die Tochter des verstorbenen bayerischen Ministerpräsidenten Franz Josef Strauss, der auch ein äh.
Kanzler für Frieden und Freiheit.
Kanzler für Frieden und Freiheit werden wollte, sehe ich hier gerade ein schönes Wahlplakat mit Franz Josef Strauß und Monika, äh, damals wahrscheinlich auch noch Strauß.
Wir verlinken unter anderem auch äh einen Link auf dieses Dokument beim Europäischen Parlament. Man muss sagen, in letzter Zeit fallen mir ja einen zunehmenden Maße mal die Links auf, die noch kein harte TPS haben.
Das ist äh einer davon und zwar nicht, weil wir's nicht hingeschrieben haben, sondern weil das Europaparlament kein hat, wie ist. Äh.
Ist das tatsächlich so?
Na ja, also zumindest, wenn ich da hatte ich die Beste vorschreibe, dann passiert da nichts.
Also oh man, ey Leute, das ist doch nicht euer Ernst.
Weiterhin in dieser äh Richtlinie. Wer rechtswidrig in Systeme, IT-Systeme eingreift oder ideal illegal Daten abfängt, muss künftig damit rechnen, als Terrorist schwer bestraft zu werden.
Auch Nutzer, die ein Handbuch zum Bombenbau herunterladen, um einen Terrorakt auszuführen, könnten im Sinne der Richtlinie verurteilt werden.
Nur der Klassiker.
Gegenverdächtige sollen die Sicherheitsbehörden gemäß den Erläuterungen neben klein und großen Lauschangriffen auch
Staatstrojaner einsetzen dürfen, um eine geheime elektronische Überwachung von Gefährdern durchführen zu können. Wir haben also hier ein, ein Waren
Krautsalat an äh an Buzzwords, ne? Wir haben die Gefährder da drin, wir haben die Staatstriana da drin, wir haben Lauschangriffe da drin, wir haben Terror.
Ähm und wir haben äh Hacking, ja? Äh alles, alles in zwei Sätzen, ne? Also wer die Hacker können jetzt Terroristen sein,
das wird auch nochmal spannend, wenn dann irgendwie die Leaks purzeln über die demokratischen Parteien im Wahlkampf.
Staatstrojaner Einsatz, tolle Sache und äh offenbar dann auch hier
wer eine Handtuch zum Bombenbau herunterlegt, wird der wird bestraft, ne? Fragt man sich, warum das Handbuch zum Bombenbau überhaupt noch erreichbar war, das wird doch normalerweise direkt durch Netzsperren gesperrt. Also da kriegen wir nochmal so diesen gesamte diese
gesamte Schiene, die man eben bekommt. Mit Terror, einmal alles.
Einmal alles. Gut, das heißt, dass wir diese Websperrendiskussion demnächst dann sozusagen auch nochmal auf nationaler Ebene haben. Ich meine, Umsetzung von solchen Richtlinien äh finden ja üblicherweise nicht unbedingt sofort statt. Es handelt es gibt eine besonders hohe Motivation, das zu tun.
Die liegt hier wahrscheinlich innerhalb von Deutschland nur so begrenzt vor. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das Thema jetzt nochmal vor dem Wahlkampf äh durchgezogen wird.
Ah ja, die werden da äh das wird wieder du kannst nicht drauf einrichten, dass das so läuft wie Vorratsdatenspeicherung, ne? Also
gab's ja auch eine Richtlinie, die müssen wir jetzt umsetzen, das ist so entschieden, das ist hier die Europäische Union, muss gemeinsam und da werden auch große,
große Reden geschwung, ne?
Ja, aber ausgerechnet ist Zensur so das Thema, also hier sozusagen nochmal aufzuladen, äh kann ich mir ehrlich gesagt nicht vorstellen.
Nicht vor der Bundestagswahl.
Ich würde mich mal interessieren, was der, was der die signierte Gottkanzler dazu sagt.
Wer ist denn der designierte Gottkanzler.
Naher ist Schulz.
Ich hol's. Der ist Gottkanzler.
Ja. Welche Kanzler? Der hat's noch nicht mitbekommen, dass Mim.
Nee, heißt es.
Ja die drehen ja.
Gottkanzler Schulz oder was.
Ja, ja, die, die, die, äh, SPD dreht ja gerade schön frei. Ich finde das eigentlich ganz unterhaltsam, muss ich sagen. So aufgrund dieses.
Es gibt natürlich direkt den Twitter-Account.
Ja, ja, da gibt's nicht nur das, da gibt's viel, das äh sehr bunt. Aber ich äh wie gesagt, ich finde das finde das sehr unterhaltsam,
aber das müssen wir jetzt gerade äh gar nicht weiter vertiefen. Äh fände ich immer nur sehr interessant, was sagen wir mal, der designierte äh Kanzlerkandidat der äh SPD jetzt in diesem Wahlkampf als ehemaliger
Parlamentsvorsitzender zu solchen Themen sagt.
Bitte nochmal spannend werden. Allright, lass uns weiter äh marschieren.
Ja, eine Meldung, die wir die jetzt in der letzten Sendung empfallen ist in Mekko,
wo gibt's jetzt auch staatstriale Einsatz? Da haben wir wieder die Gelegenheit einen Vortrag vom dreiunddreißig C drei zu empfehlen und ich sehe deine Hände zur Tastatur schnallen, um jetzt schnell den Link von Media CCC zu finden,
Million Dollar Disziplins and The Restoffers war der Vortrag von den beiden Forschern vom Citysen Lab. Ähm ein,
inhaltliches Highlight des Kongresses würde ich sagen. Ähm Cityson Lab ist ja sowieso einfach mal mit äh die coolste Institution in diesem gesamten IT Security Umfeld. Ähm eine kanadische.
Äh ein kanadisches Forschungslabor, Forschungsinstitut unter äh,
Ronald Deibert. Diebert Deibert, Albert. Ähm der da ein Team hat von echt coolen äh Leuten,
die äh so Forschung machen zu Staatstrojanern. Also das, was der CCC einmal gemacht hat, hat Citysin-Lab jetzt schon mehrmals gemacht. Äh zuletzt haben wir da sicherlich auch drüber hier in der Sendung berichtet. Das war das Offenlegen
dieser Pegasus-Suite. Und da ging es äh um den Angriff auf oh man, jetzt lässt du mich aber schwimmen. Ich glaube, Ahmed Mazur hieß der junge Mann.
Den Namen habe ich schon mal gehört.
Ähm der äh eine so eine Fishing-SMS bekommen hatte, die ihn irgendwie komisch vorkam und äh da haben dann die Citysin-Lab-Leute,
ähm dran gesucht. Ähm haben den Achmed Mazur und haben diese haben also die
Den Link in der SMS nicht geklickt und dann haben sie ähm die Situation Lableute da die geklickt haben, die Myware runtergeladen und haben festgestellt, haben eben eine
eine Malware fürs iPhone gefunden, die drei Zero Days ausgenutzt hat, um da eine Trojanerinfektion,
anzubringen, also 'ne hochprofessionelle,
Trojaner Suite. Und genau die gleiche ähm also da gibt's diesen schönen Vortrag beim Kongress und genau diese gleiche Paylote,
wurde nämlich jetzt geschickt an.
Ernährungswissenschaftler.
Ernährungswissenschaftler in Melko. Die sich für eine.
Sodasteuer aussprechen.
Sie sind Unterstützer der zweitausendvier eingeführten. Oh, die gibt's sogar schon. So da Steuer, da sagt man also, wir, wir wollen, dass diese Softdoings teurer werden.
Damit äh Kinderalternative Produkte aufsuchen.
Die Obisity ist nämlich in Mexiko ein echtes Thema. Also da ist man fett. Da stehen sie mittlerweile die Amerikaner nichts mehr. Also es war jetzt nicht,
soll nicht abwertend klingen, aber es gibt, es gibt ein Übergewichts, ein nennenswertes Übergewichtsproblem und äh wenn man da halt mal äh
Ja, durch das Land gezogen ist, wie ich's schon mal getan habe, dann merkt man halt einfach so, dass es halt so
Drink ist halt einfach immer süße Plörre und Cola, Fanta und alle anderen möglichen Marken,
und an der Stelle da mal eine Steuer anzusetzen ist sicherlich nicht der
größte Fehler, aber da gibt's natürlich Widerstand und das führt eben schon dazu, dass allein nur Ernährungswissenschaftler, Wissenschaftler wohlgemerkt, die sich an dieser Stelle einfach mal aus äh gegebenenfalls rationalen Gründen ähm
ge
oder für ein solches Projekt äh einsetzen, dass äh ja hier Gruppen, ihre Kraft und ihre Möglichkeiten einsetzen, diese zu bespitzeln und das eben so weit geht hier sogar Trojaner zum Einsatz zu bringen
so viel zum Thema
nur bei nennenswerten Straftaten und und gegen die böse Mafia vorzugehen et cetera, weil dafür brauchen wir das ja mal halt wieder das alte Problem, dass eben solche Methoden, die.
Also diese diese Ernährungs.
Sind nicht per se begrenzt auf die bösen Jungs, sondern das kann halt im Prinzip für alle eingesetzt werden und im Fallfall wird das dann eben auch getan.
Diese Ernährungswissenschaftler haben eine Medienkampagne mit dem Ziel gestartet, diese Steuer zu verdoppeln
und eine Woche später erhielten sie die ersten Fishing SMS mehrere sehr verstörende irgendwie deine Tochter hat einen schweren Unfall, äh klicke hier, um zu sehen, in welchem Krankenhaus sie liegt. Ähm dein Vater ist tot, hier die Information zur Beerdigung und
Du bist ein Arschloch, Simon, während du arbeitest, ähm mache ich was mit deiner Frau
hier ist ein Foto, ja und wollten also aggressiv die dazu bringen, diese diese Links zu klicken und dann eben diesen Trojaner.
Auf die, auf diese Ernährungswissenschaftler anzusetzen. Das ist natürlich schon,
Übel. Das heißt, ne, stehen hier nicht nur in dem Verdacht, Straftäter zu überführen oder Dissidenten einzuschüchtern, was schon übel genug ist, ja? Also gerade wieder mit äh wieder mit äh Achmed Masur umgegangen wird und so, ne.
Ist schon übel genug, jetzt auch noch für die Geschäftsinteressen von korrupten Politikern und ihren Verbündeten in der Wirtschaft.
Wunsch, die Staatstrojaner sind wirklich eine ganz feine Sache. Toll, dass wir auch in Deutschland uns dafür immer wieder äh engagieren und die rechtlichen Grundlagen schaffen, dass so etwas geschehen wird.
Links zu klicken, ne? Da denkt man ja immer so als Nerd, man wäre ja komplett davon befreit, ne. Aber es gibt so Links, die klicke ich eigentlich auch immer ganz gerne an, wenn ich E-Mails bekomme, weiß.
Klick my what hunny pussy.
Nee, nee, da weiß ich ja Bescheid. Nee, aber der Ansatzcripe from Sislist äh Links.
Ja, der ist.
Wundere ich mich schon lange, dass das noch nicht so das Einfallstor schlechthin ist, weil.
Den checke ich auch immer vorher nochm.
Ja, ich gucke mir das so an und so.
Ja
Nicht schön. Nicht schön.
So, dann Videoüberwachung. Wir haben ja über das Videoüberwachungsverbesserungsgesetz gesprochen
und äh die Deutsche Bahn will dann natürlich auch hier in der in der in der im der Datenreichtumsgesellschaft des einundzwanzigsten Jahrhunderts äh nicht
hinten anstehen.
In der Datensouveränität.
Datensouveränität in am Berliner Südkreuz ehemals Papenstraße, ne? Hieß der früher ähm ein relativ großer ähm.
S-Bahn, Horrorhof, ne?
Na das, ne, das sind.
Nee, da fahren auch richtige Züge.
Ja klar, das ist äh also Südkreuz ist ja Teil der äh neu gebauten
Fernstreckeninfrastruktur, das heißt, dass es quasi eben mit der Name sagt, das Südkreuz, da wo halt die Züge aus dem Norden, vom Hauptbahnhof, äh, kommen, dort nochmal zwischenhalten, bevor sie rausfahren,
es aber eben mit dem S-Bahn Ring. Verbindet von daher ein wichtiger, wenn aber auch überschaubarer, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes des Bahnhof ist.
Ja und er möchte, da möchte die Deutsche Bahn jetzt testen ähm intelligente Videoüberwachung,
Diese Kamera ist ein kleines Wunderding. Sie soll durch,
Eine Gesichtserkennung Menschen herausfiltern, die auf einer Liste von Verdächtigen gespeichert sind. Zudem soll sie abgestellte Gegenstände etwa Koffer oder Pakete, die längere Zeit nicht bewegt wurden, registrieren
und auch das typische Verhalten von Taschendieben soll sie erkennen. Schreib wer.
Der Tagesspiegel, nicht etwa die PR-Abteilung des Kameraherstellers, wie äh
bei Netzkritik Org korrekt angemerkt wird. Nein, der Tagesspiegel. Tagesspiegel ist sowieso eine eine Lanze des unabhängigen Journalismus, ja? Da müssen wir uns irgendwie auch nochmal mit auseinandersetzen, was bei denen in letzter Zeit los ist.
Da ist irgendwas äh merkwürdig. Ja. Oh Gott.
Fake News. Aber die haben echt, also der Tagesspiegel irgendwas ist bei den also.
Irgendwas ist bei dem halt, also ich weiß auch nicht.
Denkst du in letzter Zeit denke ich da.
Vielleicht.
Also die fallen in also sind normalerweise nicht besonders auffällig gewesen, aber ähm
In den letzten Monaten fragt man sich echt was, was mit denen los ist da beim Tagesspiegel. Na ja, die finden es also super geil hier. Ähm Feldversuch am Berliner Südkreuz mit
klugen Kameras.
Tja, das ist äh natürlich interessantes Szenario, was hier beschrieben wird. Das sind so die Sachen, die wir so glaube ich so vor zehn Jahren im Chaosradio immer so äh an die Wand gemalt haben, dass das ja irgendwann mal kommen würde und dann gucken einen die Leute mal so an, also was ähm aber ist hal
Muss man sich jetzt mal klar machen, also die Zeit ist jetzt da,
Gesichtserkennung ist ohnehin kein äh sollte niemanden mehr überraschen. Das äh kann man tagtäglich äh auf allen,
also ein Gesicht
zu erkennen im Sinne von ich erkenne, dass das ein Gesicht ist, dass es schon lange überhaupt gar kein Problem, das hat jede äh Spiegelreflexkamera, jedes iPhone standardmäßig äh an Bord, das ist überhaupt gar kein Thema,
dann eine Gesichtswiedererkennung, also ein konkretes Gesicht zu erkennen, das ist äh dementsprechend auch nicht sonderlich schwierig. Ich meine, solche äh
in Anführungsstrichen Sicherheitssysteme gibt's ja nun schon äh lange. Ähm ob die dann immer so hundertprozentig funktionieren und äh nicht eine ganze Menge äh,
positiver haben, sage ich mal, jetzt äh dahin gestellt. Äh wenn man jetzt aber hier auch noch sieht, eine Liste von verdächtigen Personen und das Ganze dann auf der Bahn, frage ich mich natürlich jetzt erstmal,
Woher kommt denn diese Liste? Für die Bahn jetzt selber eine Liste von Verdächtigen Personen? Was sind das für Personen.
Wird natürlich dort den äh der Polizei äh ermöglicht, ne.
Na gut, aber heißt das, dass die Polizei dann einen direkten Zugriff auf diese Kameras hat und die Polizei, diese Kameras auf dem Bahnhof betreibt und den Datenzugriff quasi auch exklusiv hat. Ähm,
Also.
Die Bahn, Bau, also die Bahnhöfe sind ja Sache der Bundespolizei,
und ähm die Kamera löst dann einen Alarm aus für die Bundespolizei. Und äh diese Sicherheitszentralen sind natürlich hauptsächlich für die Bundespolizei da, also unwahrscheinlich für diese Seku,
Arbeitsbeschaffungsmaßnahmen, die da immer mal wieder äh rumlaufen.
Aber prinzipiell klar, jetzt die Bahn wird jetzt nicht ihre eigene ihre eigenen Terroristen zur Fahndung ausschreiben, ne?
Ja gut, aber ich meine schon mal äh eine berechtigte Frage zu fragen, äh wer ohnt hier die Datenströme und wer äh trifft die entsprechenden Entscheidungen und Zuleitungen, wie äh wird sichergestellt, dass Daten auf die Bahn vielleicht als solche selber gar keinen Zugriff haben soll im Rahmen dieser Bereitstellung
vielleicht erhält, finde ich ja auch nochmal ganz interessant, was ich noch ein bisschen scaria finde, also man muss in der natürlichen, das ist so ein bisschen auch dieselbe Fragestellung, wie sie sich auch schon bei LKW-Maut oder PKW-Maut dann später auf der Autobahn auch gestellt hat, ähm
um überhaupt erstmal einen Verdächtigen zu finden, muss man ja im Prinzip sich auch alle anschauen äh und ähm wenn man das tut,
äh wird das dann gespeichert und wenn es gespeichert wird nach welcher Maßgabe, wann wird es wieder äh gelöscht? Wer kann es zu dem Zeitpunkt äh sehen, was ist mit Backups et cetera? Als.
Du hast dann, du hast dann, du hast dann diese Situation, die wir im Moment irgendwie bei so einer Web bei so einem Website-Besuch haben, ne, dass sich da irgendeiner Track, dass du dann und dann diese Webseite besucht hast. Hast du dann mit Bahnhöfen, ne? Und das wäre jetzt so das,
erste Projekt am,
Am Ende dieser Angelegenheit steht natürlich dann äh dass du über so eine ganze Stadt überwacht wirst, ne? Wie zum Beispiel in London, diese CCTs äh sind ja nicht
Also es sind ja nicht getrennte Kameras, ist ja ein großes System. Über das du äh verfolgt werden kannst, von von Haustür zu Haustür und auch erkannt wie ist.
Genau und dann gematched wird. Und selbst wenn jetzt noch nicht unbedingt jetzt die Information vorliegt, um wen es sich dabei handelt, äh sind solche Systeme natürlich
tendenziell dazu geeignet überhaupt erstmal Individuen als solche zu unterscheiden und dann im Prinzip eben auch über längere Zeiträume
zu dokumentieren und dann ist es eigentlich ja nur noch ein ein leichtes
auf Basis dieser Daten dann vielleicht eben auch noch eine Personenzuordnung zu machen. Da muss man dann wahrscheinlich einmal nur durch Facebook durchmarschieren, äh, hat man eben diese Daten auch.
Richtig schön, ich möchte noch was zitieren hier von äh von dem Tagesspiegelatikel, der ist so schön formuliert. Bedenken der Datenschützer hat sie allerdings noch nicht beseitigt. Vor allem die Gesichtserkennung ist umstritten
weil auch persönliche Daten gespeichert werden. Wenn die Anlagen auch noch vernetzt sind, lassen sich später Bewegungsabläufe registrieren. Hier hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht enge Grenzen vorgegeben
Selbst die automatisierte Erfassung von Autokennzeichen hatten die Richter beanstandet. Dabei allerdings Schlupflöcher gelassen.
Jetzt kommt das Fazit des Autors. Möglicherweise muss vor dem Einsatz der modernen Kameras das Gesetz geändert werden. Es ist so geil, oder?
So wird hier, ne, also wir müssten nochmal das Gesetz ändern. Hier gibt's äh es ist.
Genau, äh fällt noch auf den zweiten Scary äh Teil noch eingehen, der hier noch so äh auf Passau erwähnt wurde. Also, Gesichtserkennung, Menschen herausfiltern, Verdächtige, okay,
ja, dann soll sie abgestellte Gegenstände, Koffer oder Pakete, die längere Zeit nicht bewegt wurden registrieren. Da gehe ich sogar noch mit. Also.
Die Para mit den Koffern. Also ich meine, das ist natürlich auch so wie oft war das jetzt eigentlich wirklich schon das Problem? Und ähm.
Ähm das ist natürlich äh,
sagen wir mal, argumentierbar, ob ob das jetzt eigentlich wirklich ein Problem ist und ähm sagen wir mal, es ist ein Problem, dann könnte man das ja vielleicht äh gutheißen,
Aber dann das typische Verhalten von Taschendieben soll erkannt werden,
Da wird's natürlich schon mal schwierig, weil dann äh kommt man auch so ein bisschen mit diesem, ich mache ja nichts Böses, weil ich bin ja auch nirgendswo registriert und nach mir wird ja auch nicht gefahren. Das fällt so ein bisschen weg, weil was ist denn noch mal gleich das typische Verhalten von Flaschendieben.
Die nebenan die Taschen weg.
Nee, ich glaube, die begeben sich erstmal in die Nähe von irgendjemand. Also meine meinen sie den Klauvorgang, erkennen sie den Diebstahl einer Tasche oder erkennen sie das typische Verhalten eines.
Die erkennen einfach Ausländer. So einfach geht das.
Na toll.
Ja, also meinst doch nicht, dass das so ein System irgendwie frei von Bayers ist.
Nein, nein, meine ich nicht. Ich sage ja nur, das sind Frage äh Fragen, die halt jetzt hier aufkommen.
Fünfundneunzig Millionen Euro,
die Deutsche Bahn sich zur Seite gelegt, um sie in den kommenden Jahren in Videotechnik zu investieren,
und äh schon im August hatte der Innenminister de Maizire auf Anfrage der Grünen gesagt man wolle den Nutzen intelligenter Videoanalysetechnik an einem Pilotbahnhof testen,
Herzlichen Glückwunsch Bahnhof Südkreuz.
Ja, das wird schön. Muss mal wieder lustige Brillen tragen.
Ja, Südkreuz ab jetzt nur noch mit Perücke und Brille.
Auf dem Laufenden nur noch nur noch Gruselclowns rum, die nicht mehr erkannt werden möchten. Na toll.
Du, das ist äh freiwillig, ne?
Natürlich dann auch die ausführliche Sicherheitsüberprüfung äh durch die äh Beamten anordnt und an Ort und Stelle geben lassen. Das ist eine kurze Cavity Surch und dann geht's auch schon weiter mit der Bahn.
Next Point.
Die vorher Fluggastvorratsdatenspeicherung.
Ist ja auch so ein Thema, was äh wo wir die EU-Vorgabe,
im Prinzip verloren haben, also Fünfjährige Flugpassagiere, Passagier, Datenspeicherung,
muss jetzt nationales Recht werden, äh kostet äh achtundsiebzig Millionen Euro äh spätestens Mai zwanzig achtzehn wollen wir dann äh in Deutschland auch dem Vorbild der USA,
entsprechen und diese Flugpassagierdaten sammeln und sie automatisiert mit Fahndungs- und Antiterrordateien abgleichen.
Und äh zur Auswertung bringen. Ja.
Also auch für ihn, auch für Inlandsflüge.
Och, du schätze mal so gemeine Fragen. Ähm es steht jetzt hier keine weitere Beschränkung auf.
Ja, das sehe ich nämlich auch nicht.
Internationale Flüge? Äh doch die Option Nebenflügen aus der EU hinaus auch innereuropäische Strecken zu erfassen, will Berlin,
Nutze natürlich so eine Option, die man dazu buchen kann. Die nehmen wir doch direkt noch mit. Einmal volle Bude, ne? Was soll der Geiz, ne? So, das ist doch in Ordnung.
War billig zu haben.
Begehrte Informationen geben wir anderen Sicherheitsbehörden weiter. Das Ganze landet dann beim Bundeskriminalamt und äh das Bundeskriminalamt wird sie dann
anderen Sicherheitsbehörden inklusive der Geheimdienste weitergeben. Krass und wir boah,
Meine Güte, jährlich nochmal fünfundsechzig Millionen Kosten, einmal achtundsiebzig, um den Mist einzurichten, dann nochmal fünfundsechzig jährliche Betriebskosten.
Die Luftfahrtunternehmen werden schätzungsweise bis zu drei Komma neun sechs Millionen Euro aufwenden müssen.
Das wird uns alles total sicher machen, glaube ich.
Schon echt krass.
Dauert nicht mehr lange und dann haben wir dasselbe noch mit äh Bahntickets.
Meine Güte.
Ja, fahren wir fahren wir noch irgendwie. Ich ich kaufe mir jetzt irgendwie noch so einen Oldtimer oder so, dass ich so ein altes Auto habe, weißt du? Ohne GPS, ohne ohne Elektronik, so ein Fluchtfahrzeug, was man da nicht irgendwie
noch nicht die Fernabschaltung hat, ne? Mit mit Verbrenner so, der muss sich, muss ich irgendwie schwarz im Keller Benzin äh raffinieren,
Hä? Ich bin ein Schwarzbrenner und äh und fahre dann mit diesem Auto äh of the Grid, ja, mit mit Maske auf äh und ohne Kennzeichen fahre ich dann durch den Wald, damit ich mich bewegen kann, ohne erfasst zu werden.
Ja, also auf jeden Fall, das ist etwas, was, was, was jetzt doch akut droht, ne? Ich meine, bei den Fluggastdaten war's so ein bisschen naheliegend und äh
was ja was als nächstes kommen könnte sind Bahndaten, also Bahnreisen und soweit sozusagen. Ich meine da hat man ja noch nicht,
die Situation, dass jetzt jeder, der in einem Zug sitzt, sich auch dafür meldet, aber in dem Moment, wo halt Tickets verkauft werden, Büro gemacht werden, Reservierungen gemacht werden
kann das durchaus natürlich Begehrlichkeiten bringen, kann man natürlich sagen, ja, bringt ja gar nichts, weil es ja immer noch möglich, äh, quasi anonym zu reisen, sich anonym Tickets zu kaufen, äh, was dann wahrscheinlich dann im nächsten Schritt auch eingeschränkt werden würde, sodass man überhaupt kein Ticket mehr kaufen kann, ohne irgendwie einen Ausweis zu zeigen
et cetera pp. Ähm ja und äh was die äh Automobil,
Automobilität betrifft, müssen wir uns glaube ich auch nicht zu viel äh Sorgen machen äh
günstig an Versicherungen kommen, heißt demnächst äh seine Datenprofile abzuliefern et cetera. Also ich denke, es lohnt sich hier auch nochmal ein bisschen äh Widerstand aufzubauen, weil es geht ja irgendwie echt mal gar nicht.
Die Vermessung der Welt.
Gut Linos, ich denke, äh damit haben wir es aber dann haben wir es jetzt aber für diese Woche, wa?
Damit haben wir die äh schlechten Nachrichten für diese Woche.
Soweit zusammengef.
Soweit zusammengefegt, dass wir nur bis Montag uns Zeit lassen müssen, um uns nochmal mit dem NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss auseinanderzusetzen und dann sind wir eigentlich auch gewappnet für neue, schlechte Nachrichten. Dann haben wir sie durch.
Ach ja.
Dann bleibt mir eigentlich nur noch zu danken und zwar dem Michael.
Was ist das denn jetzt? Oh Mann, Scheiße, das machen.
Paketlieferung.
Makrofon.
Hallo.
Mein Name ist Doktor Daas von der University of Goat, dann Marieel Scientis former Proper University.
Oh, ihr.
E-Mails Adidas. Doktor Wörl von der University of Ruhr. I das Notive Next siehst,
to Google im Internet.
Äh
Als Sensor Mini Mails Tobama. Donald, Erip Lighty Medienklee
Clim mit Change Dus Notice siehst du dieser Complete Fake News, Fake News, Dom believe, dom believe, don't look at me like this, don't look at me like this, don't belift is, in Indien, der ist Nostag, Singles Global Woming, you anders stand
Days nothing. Bekannt Event, der kann Event Spell äh Domain Nebenreit, Maisan ist Domäne im Hauptgenuss, Bälle, Domin, Anisasking vor Cybertag.
Redirekted. Let's do cyberettec. Log Buchnetzpolitik Punkt DE. Genau, der die ist no meines. Log Buchnetzpolitik Punkt DE, Max Cyberattack, and Remace Mincorre.